en este vídeo vamos a hablar de varias
fuerzas en el contexto de los diagramas
de cuerpo libre aquí tenemos una mesa y
sobre esta mesa tenemos un bloque en
reposo cuáles son las fuerzas que están
actuando sobre este bloque para
responder a esto vamos a dibujar un
diagrama de cuerpo libre en donde nos
vamos a enfocar solamente en el bloque
recuerden que en un diagrama de cuerpo
libre solamente vamos a analizar las
fuerzas que están actuando sobre un
objeto del sistema qué es lo que pasa
con este bloque suponemos que este
bloque se encuentra en el planeta tierra
y que está en reposo como el bloque se
encuentra en la tierra va a tener un
peso porque está la fuerza de gravedad
actuando sobre este bloque vamos a
dibujarla en el diagrama es una fuerza
hacia abajo con magnitud
efe sub g o también podemos llamarla wv
y aunque este bloque está en contacto
con la mesa que quizá está en contacto
con la tierra el peso o la fuerza de
gravedad es una fuerza de largo alcance
aún si este bloque se encontrara en
órbita seguiría teniendo interacción
gravitacional con la tierra el planeta
seguiría jala
hacia él pero regresando al diagrama de
cuerpo libre si esta fuerza fuera la
única que estuviera actuando sobre el
bloque entonces el bloque aceleraría
hacia abajo pero suponemos que está en
reposo por lo que debe existir otra
fuerza que está contrarrestando a la
fuerza de gravedad cuál será esa fuerza
pues es la fuerza de la mesa que empuja
al bloque esta fuerza que actúa en
dirección perpendicular a la superficie
de un objeto se le conoce como fuerza
normal su magnitud se denota con la
letra f mayúscula sub n veamos otro
ejemplo pero ahora en lugar de tener el
bloque sobre una mesa vamos a tener el
bloque colgando del techo mediante una
cuerda pero nuevamente todo está en
reposo los invito a que dibujen un
diagrama de cuerpo libre para este
ejemplo nuevamente solo nos interesa el
bloque seguimos suponiendo que se
encuentra en el planeta tierra por lo
que seguimos teniendo la fuerza de
gravedad que actúa hacia abajo pero que
es lo que evita que el bloque acelere
hacia abajo pues tenemos esta cuerda que
lo sostiene que lo está jalando esta
fuerza que jala
como tensión así que aquí tenemos una
fuerza hacia arriba que equilibra la
fuerza de gravedad a veces esta fuerza
se denota con la letra t mayúscula o con
efe subte ahora hagamos las cosas un
poco más interesantes vamos a combinar
estas cosas y veremos una nueva fuerza
aquí dibujamos el suelo y dibujamos un
bloque sobre el suelo además el bloque
va a tener una cuerda que lo va a jalar
con una fuerza de magnitud
efe subte porque es una fuerza de
tensión pero el bloque no se va a mover
como será el diagrama de cuerpo libre
para este bloque hacemos lo mismo
dibujamos el bloque y en la dirección
vertical vemos que tenemos lo mismo que
hay en el primer escenario tenemos la
fuerza de gravedad o el peso del objeto
con dirección hacia abajo y magnitud f
subjefe que será contrarrestada por la
fuerza normal que actúa del suelo al
bloque el suelo sostiene al bloque
puedes evita que el bloque acelere hacia
abajo la fuerza normal actúa hacia
arriba y tiene magnitud f sub n y qué
pasa en la dirección horizontal ya
dijimos que el bloque está siendo jalado
a la derecha con una fuerza de magnitud
efe subte así que lo dibujamos en el
diagrama de cuerpo libre pero también
dijimos que el bloque está en reposo por
lo que debe existir otra fuerza que
contrarresta a la fuerza de tensión con
la misma magnitud y con dirección
opuesta cuál será esta fuerza pues es la
fuerza de fricción a todos nos ha pasado
el tratar de jalar o empujar algo pesado
que no se mueve y esto se debe a la
fricción entre el suelo y el objeto la
fricción puede ocurrir porque las
superficies de ambos objetos son rugosas
o quizá porque la interacción entre las
moléculas de ambas superficies es
pegajosa los objetos se atraen entre sí
y se resisten al movimiento en esta
situación tenemos que la fuerza de
fricción contrarresta a la fuerza de
tensión la fuerza de fricción es
interesante porque siempre se opone a la
dirección en la que se quiere mover el
objeto ahora que hemos visto todos estos
casos vamos a hacer un escenario un poco
más complejo aquí tenemos una repisa que
tiene un peso de 10 newtons sobre esta
repisa y un objeto que pesa 5 newtons la
repisa está sostenida por cables el
objeto se encuentra justo en el medio de
la repisa y los cables están a los
extremos de esta este es el cable 1 y
este es el cable 2 los cables están
unidos al techo y para simplificar el
ejemplo
suponemos que los cables no tienen peso
cuál será el diagrama de cuerpo libre
para este objeto que pesa 5 newtons y
que está sobre la repisa pues esto es
análogo al primer escenario que vimos
dibujamos el objeto tenemos la fuerza de
gravedad que actúa sobre el objeto con
dirección hacia abajo con una fuerza de
magnitud de 5 newtons la cual es
equilibrada con otra fuerza de la misma
magnitud 5 newtons pero con dirección
hacia arriba la fuerza normal es de 5
newtons hacia arriba y para no
confundirnos escribimos que este es el
peso del objeto
wv con esto tenemos el diagrama de
cuerpo libre para este objeto de 5
newtons de peso recordemos que como este
es el diagrama de cuerpo libre de este
objeto no consideramos ningún otro
elemento al dibujarlo ahora dibujemos el
diagrama de cuerpo libre de la repisa
dibujamos la repisa y los invito a qué
pausa en el vídeo y traten de dibujar el
diagrama por su cuenta
conocemos el peso de la repisa que es de
10 newtons dibujamos la fuerza de
gravedad que actúa sobre la repisa y
tiene una magnitud de 10 newtons
esta es la única fuerza que actúa hacia
abajo no porque tenemos este objeto
encima de la repisa y la gravedad actúa
sobre este objeto con una fuerza de 5
newtons lo que ocasiona que el objeto
empuje hacia abajo a la repisa esta
fuerza que empuja hacia abajo es una
fuerza normal y se debe a que la fuerza
de gravedad está actuando sobre este
objeto dibujamos otra fuerza que va
hacia abajo que tiene una magnitud de 5
newtons y que debemos ver como una
fuerza normal pues es una fuerza de
contacto que actúa desde el objeto a la
repisa suponiendo que todo esto está en
reposo entonces deben existir fuerzas
que están equilibrando todo esto de
dónde vienen esas fuerzas pues vienen de
los cables que están sujetando la repisa
tenemos la fuerza de tensión del cable 1
que llamamos te sube 1 y la fuerza de
tensión del cable 2 que este sub 2 y
para que esto no se mueva entonces la
magnitud de t sub uno más la magnitud de
t sub 2 debe ser igual a 10 newtons más
5 newtons con esto hemos visto de forma
general varias fuerzas que se
encontrarán en las
física analizadas en el contexto de los
diagramas de cuerpo libre nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo